so I feel like everybody else on eg
Canada has had a chance to sit down with
you guys so I feel really honored that I
finally get my turn they're the best for
last
well thank you congratulations on this
new album it's it's amazing and it's fun
and it's interesting and the title
heartbreak is you know an obvious
question right out of the gate so where
did the name of heartbreak come from
well it's a name of a song on the album
and it was your words to words yes it's
a little bit of a play on words the song
itself is really a empowering message of
just instead of just jumping from one
relationship to the next like you're
going to give your heart a break is
really find find yourself even in the
midst of like this you know kind of well
or a hard time you know in that and that
you want to be your best self when
you're ready to jump into the next thing
so when my favorite lines in it is them
so I'm sleeping like a queen and the
California king I make and it's like
until I'm ready
and just like fully confident I'm not
going to just be in a relationship to be
in one nice a lot of people say you know
there's there's artists like Gwen
Stefani and Blake Shelton and all kinds
of people that create great songs out of
heartbreak where do a lot of your songs
come from does it do you write some of
your best stuff when you're heartbroken
or you see another loved one go through
a heartbreak or I don't know you know I
think that's the nice thing about to
being in a trio you know and having
someone else to bounce ideas off of to
you know so like you know early on I
remember first single love to live here
we wrote because Hillary had like just
broken up with her boyfriend and and she
was just you know we're like all right
look that face was on Karen
let's Bank off your heartbreak here
let's pray coffee that you know and so
for the girls like right right a lot of
nostalgic songs too though for some
reason we always look back I think I
think that's just a natural thing
looking back at like past love with such
you know like different glasses yeah you
know it was amazing and you know what
you wish they would have done
differently what you wish you would have
done differently or that it was just
beautiful in its place in time and all
of it it's so much too
to pull from from especially like first
time where I mean that's where the bulk
of I think our content comes from I mean
but you know as a songwriter after like
we can continue to tap into that you
know even though we've all got kids and
families now I mean it's not hard for us
to go back to those moments you know
when you're 18 and 21 and going through
all those big life moments you know we
love digging digging deep for those now
you write a lot of your songs but you
also have some couple other people
writing as well is it harder for you to
let someone in and you sing someone
else's songs hard for you to accept that
as something in here no I don't know
it's always been something that you know
because we ride a lot you know a lot of
times if we hear a song that it's either
something that we just felt like it's
not a song that we can write yeah
like you look good for instance like it
was one of the only two songs like this
record that we didn't write and the
first time we heard it was like man we
need a song like that that's just a live
show fun the horns and don't yeah an
amazing song should make you either want
to dance you know cry or my clothes and
yeah the same song but so you know not
every song needs to be this like
thought-provoking thing you look good
just I don't know it makes me think
about like the nights with like my wife
and I you know probably we don't feel
like you know as young as we used to
when we go out we get dressed up or like
you're looking good darlings yeah you
get to us I guess get out there let's
have fun so we you know we still like to
get on still got it we got to look
really good yeah that's true now you
look good you know that's sort of it can
be seen as a pick-up line which then
kind of pushes me towards what was your
favorite push-up line pushup like what
is your favorite of that is my favorite
pickup line is I just it's a push-up
yeah what is your favorite line or the
worst one you've ever heard um one of
the worst ones I've ever heard is do you
have a map because I just got lost in
your eyes oh like that someone ought to
do with that legit that's amazing that's
amazing
that's a goodie like you know like yeah
there's a there's another one too you
must be from
Genesee cuz you're the only ten I see
yeah that's gonna be good
sounds like medium good yeah I'm good
but what I always thought about if it
was if you were being really overly
funny and you like where it was obvious
like hey kind of an icebreaker it's like
you know you start with something like
that it's like did that work was that
good you know I felt medically yeah it's
like you kind of do that I was like did
that work on you and you're like how it
was funny
let me buy you a drink so do you have
any intelligence that's a good pickle
that you like man I've got a rusted
arrested van outside
no I'm covering a lot of his past drove
a minivan when we started dating because
he's a drummer and his apartment he was
living in didn't have room to store his
drums
nor did you have the money to store them
himself so his minivan became like his
own storage unit so I have to say like I
fell in love with a guy who's driven
minivans like every second quarter
you're like that is a title to a song
right I love you and your minivan I love
you and remember yeah exactly that's the
worst you give it oh gosh I get too
nervous I always claim up when I tell
the girls I mean I'm married now but
yeah talk to one girl in it well yeah we
good yeah is getting nervous though